this is actually reaction involves two
elements we've got zinc and we've got
sulphur and when you combine the two and
heat them up something spectacular
happens
so we've got our zinc which is our gray
powdered metal here and then here's the
sulfur we're going to mix them together
just by putting them into a glass beaker
so you can see the colors mix
okay so what's going to happen is I'm
just going to gently rotate the beaker
so that the to mix like so no that's
mixed together we're going to go over to
the fume hood and pour it into a pile
middle
we've got mixture of our zinc and sulfur
in order to start the reaction we're
going to need a source of heat and
instead of using a flame or anything
like that we're actually going to use a
hot metal rod to get that reaction
started Neil's going to be in charge of
the bow torch and I'm going to hold on
to the rod okay
I work to treat happy customer very
happy I liked how actually bounced off
my lab coats it's a good job I was
wearing my safety gear otherwise we
would have been in trouble and the stuff
that's left is zinc sulfide this is a
very simple reaction zinc and sulfur
giving you sync sulfide that's the white
powder that you're seeing there
you
[Music]